*cheery music plays*
Hi ladies.
Hey baby. Why don't you smile for me? Huh? Just gimme a little smile. Come on!
Hey Neddy! I need five copies of this. Thanks.
Hey Ned. Sorry to bother you. Could you do me a huge favor? I need five copies of this? That'd be great. Thanks!
Hey Lauren!
Hey Caitlin! Your hair looks amazing!
Aww! Thank you!
Hey Buddy!
Hey what's up?
Hey man have you been working out? You look good.
Uhh...Yeah actually. Thanks.
That's so cool. I'm so glad.
Hey. What's going on with that guy Brian?
Oh we're not really talking anymore.
Oh my God! What happened? Let's talk about it.
Yeah... Yeah. Last Monday was when it got really weird...
Hey so I haven't seen Amanda around lately. You guys alright?
We're not really talking at the moment.
So guys... another round?
Yes.
Cheesecake?
Awesome!
Umm...
No I think I'm ok.
What?
Don't be ridiculous!
I'm sort of watching my weight a little bit.
Dude. Come on. He's in. I'm in.
Come on.
Ok! Cheesecake! Happy?
Perfect!
Ok. Yeah.
2 more rounds!
3 more rounds!
Ooo!
I'm so happy.
*laughter*
*street sounds*
Are you sure you're not cold?
No. I want you to have it.
So how was your day?
Good.
How was yours?
Good. Just a day.
*Cheery music plays*
Music ends.